welcome back to the stronger buy science
podcast
it's our final episode for the calendar
year of 2020 and this is a very
science-heavy episode even by our
standards
after some good news and feats of
strength we revisit optimal protein
recommendations and whether or not fish
oil is a worthwhile supplement
we also take another look at a
previously discussed study about
implementing strength blocks to enhance
hypertrophy
and how much the typical lifter should
worry about muscle glycogen depletion
finally greg explores a couple
fascinating studies that might give us
some clues about the biological factors
that limit how large a muscle fiber can
get
as always thanks for listening and we
hope you enjoy the show
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only
full-time podcast host
eric trexler today i am going to be
joined by a very special very temporary
guest co-host named greg knuckles
of course we do have a good news segment
to start things off today
but before we get into the good news i
want to wish happy holidays
and a happy new year to all listeners
whatever holidays you might be
celebrating we sincerely hope
that you do enjoy them so you want to
get into some good news
uh yeah let's do it all right uh why
don't you go ahead and start
uh yeah so um big raymie
finally broke through and won the mr
olympia
uh i've been a big fan of him for a long
time
uh who i've talked about this on the
podcast before
i just like big freaky bodybuilders like
that
in my opinion especially now that
there's like the classic bodybuilding
division
where you know the the aesthetic guys
are
uh speaking of which this isn't on the
outline but like did you see any
any pictures from that tracks from the
classic
yeah uh i did dude bumstead looks insane
yeah uh but anyway yeah like that's
where the aesthetics are now
i just want to see the freaks in the
open division uh and big raymie
has definitely been a freak among the
freaks for a while
uh and just couldn't dial in his
conditioning for the stage
some people say that there were also
politics going on behind the scenes
i don't know about that uh seems very
plausible
i won't pretend i know enough about ifbb
bodybuilding to confirm
or refute that uh but it was good to see
him finally break through and win one
and boy did he deserve it uh he
he was the biggest dude on stage by far
and just brought insane conditioning
this year
uh so yeah that in my mind counts as
good news
yeah for context what was your favorite
version
of ronnie coleman
oh man i forget what year it was
maybe 2003 uh my favorite version of
ronnie was like
when he stopped having coleman-esque
conditioning but just got
freakier than ever yeah the the one
where
his uh his night show posing routine he
came out with like the crown and cape
yeah that was my favorite version of
ronnie yeah so
i i kind of liked early career ronnie
better but but i mean your
your bodybuilding preferences are are
quite clear
we've talked about this before my
favorite bodybuilder of all time is
marcus rule
yeah and that that should give an
indication of what i look for in
bodybuilders
yeah yeah that that's that's fair um no
but uh
big raimi he looked awesome and he is
one of those bodybuilders for the
longest time
i used to follow the ifbb uh a lot
closer than i currently do
but for the longest time it was just
like he was so big
and you're just waiting for the day that
he'd be able to pull it all together
show up in
really really good shape really good
conditioning and he did it which is
which is awesome
okay so for my good news segment uh
we're going to the animal kingdom
that's my sweet spot so uh
like all good news it starts with bad
news there were some brush fires
in australia some pretty severe ones and
it was
feared that the world's smallest possums
were actually extinct
as a result of the the really bad brush
fire season
uh in australia recently uh you know the
fires wiped out over 80 percent of their
habitat but i know what you're thinking
greg
did anybody check kangaroo island that
is the first thing i was thinking yeah
well turns out they didn't check
kangaroo island until now but
they were over on kangaroo island and
they found some of these little fellas
so so they were quite concerned that
these little possums were extinct
but they are good to go uh ready to
fight back
and uh and repopulate kangaroo island
and these
these little these little possums are
seven grams
uh they are very very cute so if you
want to see some cute possums
uh i'll put a link in the show notes you
can check them out
now the comments were a bit mixed for
the article that i saw
um one person said this was
possibly the best news i've heard all
day
which was i thought that was nice
another commenter said
it looks smug so i don't know i guess
some people just don't like the look of
these
these little possums uh arguably a smug
type of possum i don't know but uh
good news to see that they are alive and
well and ready to fight back
you always love to see happy and healthy
possums that's right
okay dude the small versions of just
like normal ass
animals always so cute always i don't
know if we've talked about this on the
podcast before
uh but dear listener if
you have never heard of
uh poodoo p-u-d-u
uh it is a it's the smallest deer
in the world lives in south america um
mostly in chile and argentina
dude it is the cutest thing they are so
tiny
uh they only get up to about 20 pounds
and uh
yeah so if you need a pick-me-up in your
day
just uh take two seconds and google
image search
poodoos awesome all right
what do you think about some feats of
strength yeah let's do it
um so there are
quite a few that are uh
worth talking about so i'm not going to
dwell on
any one of them too terribly long
but so i'll uh i'll just get right into
it so
gabrielle pena who i had not heard of
before but i think
he's a competitive strong man recently
recorded
the heaviest trap bar deadlift ever so
it was
1160 pounds or 526 kilos
uh i will say just looking at the video
the
he's pulling from the high handles and
the high handles are
quite high so just in terms of like
purely the most impressive deadlifts
ever i don't think that this
tops thor's deadlift with a barbell of
501 kilos but i mean
it's 1100 plus pounds for a very
deadlifty movement
uh and no one has ever done that before
so
props to him very very impressive stuff
uh jackson powell who we've talked about
on
the podcast before teenage strength
phenom
18 years old squatted 410 kilos or
about 904 pounds in competition and also
totaled
2000 plus in sleeves um
[ __ ] wild uh last time we talked
about him i i feel like the last time we
talked about him it was the first time
he squatted 800 and that wasn't that
long ago
uh so anyway very strong kid uh moving
on
possibly arguably the crown jewel
of untested uh raw powerlifting
is the raw with wraps super heavyweight
record
that is you know obviously the most
that anyone is lifting uh without
you know a bench shirt or squat suit uh
and that record was recently broken by
peter petras
he totaled 116 kilos or
257 pounds uh
knocked down that world record i will
say there was some
controversy about this one uh when i
first saw the videos
all of the lifts looked solid a side
video or like a kind of
diagonal angle of the squat started
going around
uh and it wasn't the best angle to judge
depth but
it it did look kind of iffy from that
angle but uh
i mean it wasn't it wasn't just
absolutely abhorrent
um but yeah i mean uh he got whites
and that is all that matters so congrats
to him
um dimitri nasinov
who we've also talked about on the
podcast before is
inching closer and closer to being the
first
competitor in the 181 pound or 82 and a
half kilo
weight class to deadlift 900 in
competition
uh he deadlifted i didn't do the pound
conversion i think it's 891 405 kilos
recently at the wrpf nationals or worlds
or whatever
big meat in russia um and honestly so
his previous record was 400 kilos
and the lockout looked kind of soft
somewhat iffy i thought his lockout
looked
quite a bit more convincing this time
around uh and yeah he's
i mean he lifts in kilos he's russian
i'm sure he doesn't care about being the
first 900 pound deadlifter
but boy do i care uh that's so
impressive
very very cool um so i remember when i
first got into lifting
uh like raw was just making its
resurgence
and the raw record on the books that
seemed
just the most completely untouchable was
ed cohn's 903 deadlift at 220
like it just seemed like a number that
was
completely untouchable uh and now
someone's getting pretty close to that
two weight classes lower
which like jesus christ i i
did not like i
i would i wouldn't have been shocked say
maybe five years ago
if someone at some point pulled
900 at 198 i never expected to see
numbers like this at 181
so very very impressive good for him
uh and i'm really hoping he breaks that
barrier soon
uh andrei saponzikov
a 90 kilo 198 pound
bench specialist i believe chipped his
old world record so he benched
277 kilos i should have done the pound
conversion that's
somewhere in the neighborhood of 610 i
believe um
i'm pretty sure he had the old world
record at 276
so he he chipped it uh congrats to him
uh zach myers uh broke
the all-time world record at 275
for the total uh that was previously
held by larry wheels
broke the record by about 48 pounds very
very
impressive and dominant performance top
to bottom congrats to him
uh and finally another impressive young
gun
uh jesus oliveiras he is a junior usapl
lifter
um he totaled uh
a thousand fifty five and a half kilos
or twenty three
twenty seven pounds uh that is an
unofficial
junior world record in the usa pl um
because
for world records like you have to be
competing at international meets or like
meets with enough
international qualified judges um
so it doesn't technically break that
record but in my heart it does
uh like dude that's
that's such a crazy total for uh for
someone who's 23. and
as far as like weight classes go
generally the
uh the heavyweights take a little bit
longer to mature
just because like they're bigger and
they have an enormous amount of muscle
and it takes
a long time to build that much muscle
generally like some of the lighter
weight classes like people may
hit their competitive prime like a
little bit earlier
so the fact that there's a junior
already totally over 2300
uh that's wild and i am expecting to see
enormous things from him moving forward
i've got one to add to the list yeah go
for it uh
joe stockinger is that how he says oh
yeah yeah uh
i don't know stockinger stockinger i
don't know uh
so he pulled 405 for a double
which is a lot of weight he happens to
weigh about 147 147 pounds yeah that's
that's a really good deadlift for that
weight without any qualifiers
sure well i i have a qualifier though
what is that
uh the gentleman's 90 years old
that's a lot of years yeah
that's a a year pr and for most people a
deadlift pr
you know i should uh i should crunch
some numbers
i think you could probably make the case
that he is the greatest outlier
athlete in the world in any sport
uh like i so man i i remember that
a couple years ago there was there was a
guy who was like a hundred plus
who just absolutely dusted the
100 plus hundred meter world record or
something like that so i
it it's probably some older person
who is just like the biggest athletic
outlier but i remember
going into i think it was the 2016
olympics
um 538 did a analysis
um about katie ledecky and just how far
ahead of
the rest of all other female swimmers in
the world she was like
on a z scored basis like basically take
the other
top competitors in the world see what
their
typical performances and like they're
the the variance of their performance
z scored and then see how far ahead like
various athletes are
uh and their analysis was basically that
like among olympic athletes
uh katie ledecky was was probably the
biggest outlier
uh and i was like huh i wonder i wonder
who the biggest freak is in powerlifting
that we can find
uh and at the time it was jennifer
thompson's bench press
but i mean i i wasn't thinking of age
divisions as well
and like a 400 plus deadlift regardless
of weight class at 90 years old
i feel like that has to be a bigger
outlier uh
just because like the typical 90 year
old is in fact
dead um and the ones that are alive
generally don't pull 400. i think he
actually also had
405 for a triple i don't i don't
remember if it when
if it was when he was 89 or if he was 90
at that time as well but like
this guy on most days it seems can roll
out of bed
and pull 405 for a couple or a few
yeah which is crazy he looks like he can
probably still pull like 430 40. yeah
if memory serves he pulled 450 in a meet
maybe like three years ago like i've
seen his name before
um and i think like basically he is
he's not still getting stronger which is
would be completely unreasonable to
expect
but i think like basically he is losing
strength rolling into his
10th decade of life at the typical rate
that like
40 or 50 year olds are yeah uh
that ain't normal man no not at all so
really impressive
congrats to him that's that's insane
all right so moving on we've got a new
segment
i'm calling it clarifications rigid
defensiveness and aggressive counter
attacks
and basically this is when we say a
thing someone responds to it
and then we get to choose whether we
want to offer
a humble clarification a rigid defensive
response
or an aggressive counter-attack and we
won't we won't say which is which we're
just gonna go for it
so uh last episode i talked
about a study by tagawa and colleagues
and the study was looking at
dose-response relationships between
protein intake
and the increase in lean body mass or
muscle mass
and so it was a meta analysis they used
some kind of meta regression techniques
and the general idea the whole purpose
of the study was to look at a bunch of
studies that have
given various amounts of protein and
kind of observed over
the course of the intervention how much
lean body mass was gained
and the main takeaway that i talked
about was
the inflection point you know the idea
is that
when you increase from a low protein
intake to a moderate protein intake we
expect some pretty notable
improvements some some uh real benefits
when it comes to lean mass
accretion or retention but at a certain
point
we we do expect that we'll reach a
protein intake that is essentially
for practical purposes sufficient and we
start to see that beyond a certain point
there are diminishing returns and
further increases in protein
probably don't give you as much bang for
your buck you don't see as
notable of benefits once you go beyond a
certain intake
and a lot of the papers in this area
especially the the meta-analyses and
meta-regressions are interested in
figuring out
where is that inflection point at what
point do the
really large benefits of additional
protein start to flatten out
and so there is a paper in 2018 by
morton and colleagues that said that
inflection point was probably at about
1.6
grams per kilogram this paper
by tagawa and colleagues included a lot
more studies they included studies with
both
resistance training and without
resistance training which really kind of
opened it up to
to several more studies in a larger
sample size uh so
very large uh sample of studies that
they pooled together for this analysis
and so like i said the morton study
indicated that the inflection point was
at about 1.6 grams per kilogram
in this study they had a number of
different figures with with different
covariates and stuff included
but it looked like it was probably
somewhere between 1.3 to 1.5
ish and so my takeaway that i
shared last episode is basically okay it
looks like that range that most people
kind of
advocate that 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram per day for
for lifters probably not not a bad range
to shoot for
if you want to make sure that you've got
your protein bases covered
and you want to make sure that you're
not leaving a lot of gains on the table
now i did get a little bit of pushback
for that segment
and there were two main issues two areas
to focus on
so one was basically why am i
interpreting these
figures very uh
imprecisely right so if it says the
inflection point is exactly 1.3
why am i presenting it as a range and
kind of
loosely interpreting these models as if
they're very imprecise
so why am i not taking them as extremely
literal
and extremely precise and the second
issue that came up is you know
why am i saying that 1.6 to 2.2
grams per kilogram per day is sufficient
are there any times where higher amounts
might be needed so i'm going to get into
both of those issues
i want to start with the first one which
is interpreting the figures in this
meta-analysis so there were a bunch of
different figures showing you know
as protein on the x-axis goes up we see
you know better results in terms of lean
body mass accretion and then at
a certain point along the x-axis that
that slope kind of flattens out
and some people you know kind of look at
that and
interpret the y values extremely
precisely and assume that
this line that we're seeing is is
essentially a
universally true representation of real
numbers that have been observed
um and so i want to begin by kind of
starting with an example so
imagine you're looking at a
meta-analysis that says does caffeine
enhance performance and that is it
that's as precise as we're getting
and it gives you an effect size of you
know cohen's d equals 0.2
the question is how do we translate that
into a prediction about how caffeine
is going to impact our performance of
course if we
really cared about the the answer we
would get pretty precise with our
assessment we would ask a few questions
like
well what caffeine dose am i going to
take and in what
form and how long before exercise and
am i naive to caffeine or am i
habituated to caffeine
and what is the exact specific exercise
task and
how familiar am i with that exact
exercise
task and you know the meta-analysis that
kind of fictitious uh hypothetical
meta-analysis
that effect size of 0.2 is not remotely
specific to our situation
it's it's a combination of studies with
several different characteristics that
all kind of get pooled together and
mashed together
into one kind of generalized
estimate of what kind of effect caffeine
has so
we are trying to apply it to a precise
scenario and we cannot assume
that caffeine is going to have that
exact effect size when we start to
make precise contextualized predictions
for a very specific scenario and
even if that fictitious meta-analysis
has a really narrow confidence interval
around that effect size that might be
the case if there are a ton of studies
going into it
um but that confidence interval even
though it's narrow
for this kind of imprecise estimate of
the pooled effect size
just because that confidence interval is
narrow it does not mean that we can
precisely
generalize that effect size to all
possible scenarios
the details really matter and when we
start trying to apply
things from meta-analyses or
meta-regressions we have to remember
that
you know the precision of that estimate
can only be precise
as the the actual inputs that go into
the calculation that
go into the modeling process
so shifting focus back to the protein
paper
uh greg if i asked you to describe your
current training program how would you
describe it
uh three or four days per week uh
about twice per week upwards okay stop
if your answer is anything more than yes
or no
then you're going way beyond the
precision of the models in this meta
regression oh you got me
exactly i gotcha but the idea that these
these numbers are these ultra precise
estimates that we can pull straight from
the model and insert it into real life
you can only pretend to defend that
choice if i
ask you what your training program is
and you say
yes or no anything else
beyond that is a level of precision that
did not go into the formulation of these
models
and it's really critical to consider
that when you look at
the results of a meta-analysis or a
meta-regression
now in this particular paper they did
use
some covariates to try to smooth out
some potential sources
of variation in the lean mass outcomes
and
it's really critical to remember that
using covariates is extremely
different than experimentally
controlling for something
it's usually better than nothing to use
covariates but not always
it's really only better when there's a
linear
mostly independent relationship between
the covariate and the outcome within
that data set
and that linear relationship pretty
accurately reflects the true
relationship
out in the real world between those two
variables
now in the different models presented in
this meta regression
one of the models didn't include any
covariates
another one included age sex
intervention length and resistance
training
and the the other set of models also
added weight change
as a covariate on top of those
covariates so it's critically important
to remember when you look at that
meta-regression line
the studies going into it have not been
actually equated before going in i mean
it's not like they said we're only going
to look at 12-week interventions there
are effect sizes going into this
model from studies that are two weeks or
four weeks or 12 weeks or
six months and they're leaning on the
covariates hoping that they're going to
smooth
out some of those sources of variation
and hopefully get
things kind of equated but there's a
huge
uh variety of study characteristics
representing the studies that go into
this model and we can try to use
covariates but that's an
imperfect way to handle things it's the
best we can do
but it's imperfect so i don't want it to
seem like i'm criticizing the models i'm
simply pointing out
some realities of what we have to deal
with when it comes to interpretation so
a hypothetical scenario let's say that
in this body of literature the studies
with younger subjects
just kind of tend to have more intense
training programs that provide
a more robust hypertrophy stimulus
it's not like they were intentionally
made that way but the the studies with
younger subjects
tend to have hypothetically more intense
training programs
so what happens when we adjust for age
in this model
well the model can't distinguish which
part of that age effect
is truly due to the biological effects
of age it can't separate that
from the fact that age is kind of
interrelated with training
uh stimulus in that particular scenario
so
the the age covariate is kind of
contaminated to an extent
by the confounding effect of having
training programs that
systematically differ in terms of their
program characteristics
and it could potentially adjust your
data in an unintended manner
and there's not a damn thing we can do
about that and so
one of the things you know i don't want
it to seem like i'm against using
covariates because it's
a good statistical practice but i'm
against
having a hundred percent faith that
covariates will always do exactly what
we hope they will
so whenever i see a model that has you
know four or five covariates that could
be
quite interrelated i always kind of stop
and think are there any ways that this
could have
unintended consequences on the model and
how much
imprecision does that add to our um
our applications of the model so
you know if we really could lean on
covariates that way
and just assume that they completely
handle everything exactly the way we
want them to and they are very specific
and precise and and
never alter the data or the trends in
ways that are unexpected
we really wouldn't have to bother with
all these experiments i mean
if that were truly the reality of
covariate adjustments
we could lean a lot more heavily on
observational data
and as long as we threw in the right
covariates we could get some really
really solid effect estimates and
obviously we know that
experimental control is is so key
to creating you know generalizable
findings where we can make
really good inferences about causation
so another thing i want to bring up in
this discussion
when we talk about exactly how literally
can we
interpret the values in these figures um
again i want to reiterate the
researchers did a fantastic job but this
is just kind of the nature of
of meta regression we can't treat this
as a
really really precise line that is
real in nature it's it's not real it's
not
arbitrary it exists somewhere in between
these are
adjusted values that are adjusted
on many different covariates right so
instead of thinking it as thinking of it
as an ultra precise line that
represents the real world perfectly i
look
at it that is generalizable to all real
world situations
exactly yeah i view it as more of a
cloud
you know so like could we theoretically
bump that line to the right or left
probably is it possible that you know
it's it's almost like uh
in devs we we don't have to like take
the full multiverse theory and assume
that like there's an infinite number of
lines
in an infinite number of universes but
like there there's some
there's some potential for adjustment
there right like
we should probably view it as more of a
general
ballpark estimate of the relationship
more of a cloud
than a single line that perfectly
represents that relationship
did they report r-squared values for
their
entire models who i i i'd have to go
back i don't remember if they did i kind
of don't think they did though
i don't think so but uh i'd have to go
back and check and i i don't think the
listeners want to listen to me uh
scrolling through the paper but we can
go back and check that and
if we need to make an update we can
because i mean like like that's a
consideration even if they had pretty
good model fit and
you know let's say had r values of
0.7 r squared's around 0.5 which
honestly i i would anticipate it would
be lower than that
that would that would still mean that
like you were leaving
around half or like a a
large minority of the uh like
of the variance of your data unexplained
by your model
yeah yeah i don't think they reported r
squared and for this type of modeling
it's it's actually not
super common um with meta regression so
no fault of theirs but but yeah i i
don't think they reported in r squared
or anything like that
um but anyway so like if we assume that
we're going to interpret these figures
completely literally uh well all i was
getting at with that is like
if you know if for example there are
squared values where like
0.94 or something like that then that
would be
to some degree like evidence against
what you're saying it's like well
like their models fit the data really
really well yeah uh
like these these are probably
outcomes you could interpret literally
but if it was anything below like
0.6.7 then like yeah there's
there's going to be variability around
it like the the models themselves
are what fit the data best but they
don't even come
close to perfectly fitting the data
because the data can't be perfectly fit
right yeah and i mean one of the things
that helps even if we don't have an r
squared to lean on
is just doing some
just some testing like just look at the
numbers interpret them literally and see
how you feel
you know so like uh see if the the
output of the model
fits the experimental data that you've
seen like
that's a really good way to do it and
you know if we were to interpret
these lines extremely literally we'd
have to answer some difficult questions
we'd have to answer why not lifting
and consuming 1.4 grams per kilogram
leads to two to three times more lean
mass gains than lifting
and consuming the same amount of protein
that's a difficult
question to answer we would have to
answer a question like why does not
lifting and having 2.5 grams per
kilogram
lead to less lean mass gains than not
lifting
and consuming 1.3 grams per kilogram
again i don't have a good answer to that
but but if we're interpreting the model
literally we have to sign up for that
and then another one is the model uh
really
seems to suggest no synergistic
relationship between
protein and resistance training but
there are experimental
outcomes that do seem to suggest synergy
there you know and
theoretically you can make a good case
for a synergistic relationship
or a minimum an additive effect yeah
yeah and so
i i think there are some challenging
questions where you have to say
well do the models line up with the
actual experimental evidence we do have
in lifters and i would say in some cases
it's not really a perfect fit between
model estimates and the actual
experimental data
and another thing to keep in mind is you
know we have to think of when we're
looking at the extremes of the x-axis
when we're looking at the studies that
give
three 3.2 3.5 grams per kilogram of
protein per day
the the figures show the trend line but
not the individual data points or you
know even the you know the adjusted data
points that go into the model
um but i can't imagine there are that
many studies out there giving 3.1 to 3.5
grams per kilogram
uh if there's a lot of them out there i
haven't seen them have you
no so like i'm aware of a few and uh
so for me i'm like i'm a little bit
cautious about interpreting on the
fringes
of these figures because i would imagine
most of the actual data points that
generated this line
probably exist in the middle so we get
to that point where we might not be
completely extrapolating but
most of the data that's kind of
informing the the actual estimates on
the fringes there
it's probably not actually from a series
of studies that actually gave
3.5 grams per kilogram per day of
protein
so we're just kind of extending that
trend line from the real meat of the
data
and carrying it out uh based on the
trend line that's established right
and so that's something you have to be
careful about as well and you know when
i see
all of these studies indicating or these
uh
these figures indicating benefits when
we get into that like
three 3.5 gram per kilogram range i go
back and look at the only studies i'm
aware of that actually give that kind of
protein
and include resistance training and it's
the studies by jose antonio
he's done at least a couple of them
where they put resistance trained folks
on pretty solid bodybuilding type
programs and give them
either you know 1.8 to 2 grams per
kilogram or a ton
you know 3 grams or above per kilogram
per day yeah i think one was 3.3 and one
was 4.4
yeah and when we look at the results of
those actual experimental
outcomes we don't see any benefit when
it comes to lean mass accretion
either practically insignificant and
statistically non-significant or
literally no benefit at all so yeah and
i think
um i i think one thing to consider is
just
like a model specification itself like
they they set out and basically said
like there will be
an inflection point we're gonna figure
out what that inflection point
is and we're going to see what the slope
is up to that inflection point and
beyond that inflection point
and so like to your point of you know
the they
set their inflection points at around
1.3 or like that's what they found them
to be
and then if you have if you have a lot
of studies
in say like the 1.3 to 2.2 range
and only like three or four maybe
uh in like the three plus range then
like basically when you're
when you're finding the slope of that
regression line
uh the so
if we assume that like you know like
maybe more than 1.3 is good but
like let's just say hypothetically uh
it plateaus after i don't know 2.4 2.5
just to put a random number on it
then if they like specified in the model
like hey maybe there are two break
points then then you could potentially
see that you could see like steeper
slope to 1.3
slightly shallower slope to 2.5 and then
flat from 2.5 out to 3.5 or whatever it
is
but since they predetermined that there
would just be one break point
uh if there are way more data kind of
to the left like between the break point
and like you know 2.5 or something
like that is going to have way way more
impact
on the slope of that regression line
than the
two or three data points out on the
extreme um
so yeah i mean like who knows what they
would have found if they
went with two break points instead of
one like that that's just a model
specification decision
that isn't necessarily right or wrong
but like we don't have all of the data
that went into their model so like we
can't
test that counter factual well we could
but we'd have to go in and do the entire
process
of finding all the studies they included
and extracting the data
extracting the covariates and coding
those and then doing the modeling
yeah and i'm really busy this week greg
um
but if you've got some time that'd be
cool i mean i occasionally do
volunteer to do stuff like that like you
you can back me up here
yeah uh but i mean like that's when
we're dealing with metas that maybe have
like
between eight and 20 studies
yeah there were like there were close to
100 in this one right
they're like 60 or 80. there was a lot
of studies uh yeah
yeah i'm not doing that i think yeah i
think uh 105 were included
yeah yeah meta-analysis so but yeah so
i i should also put a caveat i mentioned
that there was like
no no material benefits in those studies
by jose antonio that's
specifically referring to lean mass or
fat free mass
there were some modest benefits in terms
of fat loss but
that's ultimately just not the research
question that we're talking about you
know
so the take-home point here um i know it
seems like
last week i presented this as hey here's
this cool good paper that i like
and then i just spent like 20 minutes
saying like well here's why
none of these lines mean anything at all
um
you know i just want to reiterate the
researchers did a really nice job
they did what they set out to do i think
it's a very informative paper
my only um caveat is that i would
caution against interpreting
you know the exact uh x and y values
in these different models as being you
know
completely generalizable to all
scenarios and
we we have to remember the imprecise
nature
of how these types of models are
generated even when they're generated
very
effectively so so this is not a
criticism of the work or the researchers
this is a reality of the type of work
being done
it's a lot like with epidemiology when
we have to say like
well this is all survey stuff and you
know it's observational and you can't
really prove causation and you start
rattling off all those caveats it
doesn't mean that the researchers did a
bad job
or that the work's not valuable and
useful it just means like hey we need to
uh really think hard before we
interpret this and assume causality or
assume an
impractical level of precision from the
output of the model
so when i look at these types of papers
i look at the morton paper i look at
this paper
i look at the actual experimental data
that i'm aware of
where we have the ability to control the
duration of the intervention and the two
different protein intakes and
everybody's in the same age range and
they're all doing the same resistance
training program
when we triangulate all that data
it looks like that range of 1.6 to 2.2
grams per kilogram
is probably pretty sufficient and when
we start increasing that
up to 3 grams per kilogram and beyond i
haven't seen the experimental data that
would indicate that that's going to
provide
a really large benefit beyond what
you're getting closer to 2 grams
per kilogram now that is under the
assumption
that you are either at energy balance or
in an energy surplus
or you've got a decent amount of body
fat if
any of those scenarios apply to you then
that 1.6 to 2.2
range i think is pretty suitable and i
always air
toward the high end of that range
because you run a little
uh cost benefit analysis i think you're
better off going a little high than a
little low
so so that's kind of my take on it
however
moving on to point number two um
there are some situations where higher
amounts might be
warranted or at least worth considering
so
going above 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram but this is really
only going to apply to people who are
already quite lean and in a caloric
deficit
and pushing to get like shredded so if
you're going from lean to absolutely
shredded
and you're in a calorie deficit it might
make sense to go a little bit higher
than that previously mentioned range
another scenario where you might
consider it is if you're in an enormous
caloric deficit but i normally tell
people hey
you probably don't want to be in an
enormous caloric deficit you'd probably
rather be in a more moderate deficit
for a variety of different reasons so
the reason uh
that i presented this range in last step
in the last episode without any major
caveats is
if we looked at everyone listening to
this episode right now and said who is
like
pretty shredded and pushing hard in a
deficit to get extra shredded
it's literally only the people that are
prepping for physique competitions
at this moment and uh or like a fitness
modeling photo shoot
it's probably not a huge percentage of
our of our listeners right now what
would you estimate as a percentage there
uh one percent i was gonna say below
five
yeah so so yeah but for those
individuals
uh there's a really great systematic
review by our dear friend
the good doctor eric helms i'm gonna put
the link to it in the show notes
and you know helms is a bodybuilder is
he a friend now
i would say he's a friend of the show
not a friend of ours
he's been on the show up to this point
he has been an enemy of the show
okay then an enemy of the show that
works okay cool uh
our dear enemy the good doctor eric
helms i haven't signed a treaty with him
okay fair enough so he did a systematic
review where he he really dug into this
and he's a bodybuilder right so he was
curious about like well what about the
people who are
lean on their way to shredded and in a
deficit
and you know he looked at a number of
studies and what he
concluded was that for for resistance
trained athletes that are energy
restricted and pushing from lean to
shredded
maybe you do want to get up around 2.3
to 3.1
grams per kilogram of fat free mass
per day so that's not grams per kilogram
of total body mass that's grams per
kilogram of fat free mass
and again the numerical range was 2.3 to
3.1
and just to give an idea like a real
world scenario
so let's say i weigh 190 and i'm
16 body fat and i want to go toward the
high end of the range
at the end of my bulk so i'm gonna eat
2.2 grams per kilogram of protein at the
end of my bulk before
i start cutting so i'm eating 190 grams
of protein per day
let's say that during my cut trying to
get shredded
i cut from 190 to 160. so i lose 30
pounds and my body fat goes from 16
to 5 and i'm like shredded ready to go
if i leave my protein at 190
then my grams per kilogram of fat free
mass like i said helms's range was 2.3
to 3.1
it ends up being 2.75
so that is not necessarily a large
increase in protein
intake what you find is if you're
leaning toward the high end of that
range for people that are at neutral or
positive energy balance
and then you start cutting down to get
lean and then progress onto shredded
you find even if you don't do a lot of
manipulation with protein intake
you kind of end up in that range so like
even if you want to say well what about
the people that are lean and getting
shredded it's like well
if they followed that initial advice of
1.6 to 2.2 and air on the higher side
and then they just left it and did a cut
by removing fat and carbohydrate
by the time they're shredded they're
probably very comfortably in that range
so like yeah if you're in that range if
you're going
and pushing to get really really
shredded i do not
advise that you should be removing
protein from your diet as you get leaner
in order to kind of match your uh you
know your grams per kilogram numbers
you probably want to leave protein
stable or
if anything increase it as you go but i
just wanted to give like a concrete
example of when you see those numbers
oh wow 2.3 to 3.1 that seems like a
totally different
uh protein intervention it's really not
that different
by the time you're getting shredded even
if you don't even touch your protein
you kind of ease into that range as you
get leaner so
for those individuals yes the gram per
kilogram number should be different it
should probably exceed
1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram but that
doesn't mean
that the second you begin to cut you're
like doubling your protein intake
makes sense to me all right um i got
another one
and normally i would say you go i need
to take a break but
i'm just going to keep on pushing go off
king
so here's another one um fish oil people
are upset greg
are you up to date on fish oil i'm
really not i don't care
so dude so i got into fitness in
2000 uh well i started like doing blog
posts and stuff
maybe like 2012
like just making long waste of time
facebook comments than calling them like
a blog post
but anyway back in those days if you
just said like hey fish oil is pretty
good
it was just nothing but you know pat's
on the back hey
you did it good one dude so what
happened is
people got really intrigued by fish oil
and were very receptive to it
and then a few big studies hit that said
like hey fish oil doesn't prevent heart
attacks
and dude that pendulum swung hard dude
there was even a bigger pendulum swing
kind of on the fringes
of uh of like fitness conversations
before that
do you know of ray pete yes yeah yeah
the
he and his followers are are on the uh
guess what omega-3s will actually kill
utrain
because did you know oxidation exists
yeah
yeah so act so let me cut to the uh
cut to the point here so i on my
instagram
i make uh i do recommended reads on
mondays
where i just say hey here's a cool paper
that'll make you smarter you should read
this one
and i do other like informative posts on
thursday so if you want to check those
out
my handle's at trexler fitness it is
some of the hottest content on instagram
they're saying
a lot of people are saying actually and
uh
i had a thursday post about fish oil
just kind of talking to the camera
giving a little summary and people were
like
man fish oil is a scam and it's trash
and it's useless and somebody actually
did bring up ray pete and they're like
what do you think about this you should
debate him i was like i don't really
want to do that
so basically it seems like a lot of
people are
rightfully a little bit agitated about
fish oil and i say rightfully because
like
some people were overselling it way too
hard
and so it's only natural if you push
fish oil and say like dude
forget modern medicine we've got fish
oil now like then yeah
when it starts to actually get some
evidence accumulating and it falls short
of some of the miraculous claims people
are going to be pretty
uh pretty annoyed by that would you say
that some of those claims
flamed out i feel like you're making a
pun or a joke and i'm completely missing
it that was the i i assume still is
the uh the bio test omega-3 brand
uh and they were pushing a lot of uh
very strong claims about it it was
called flamed out flame out
why would you call a fish oil that uh
because it reduces inflammation
oh puts the flames out okay that fair
enough good
yeah so um man if you had a
if we had a smarter host who is more uh
in the know about the supplement brand
names
i'll i'll exclusively stick with
anaconda jokes from here
okay perfect yes so um anyway all these
claims get made
a few trials come out that say like hey
it's probably not as cool as we hyped it
up to be
but there's always that kind of
knee-jerk pendulum swing
and so a lot of people are like dude
there is no evidence to suggest that
fish oil
does anything useful and it certainly
doesn't impact cardiovascular
risk in any way and it's like well wait
a minute
that's a little bit hyperbolic like
that's a little bit too extreme so like
there are data showing inverse
relationships between fish intake
fish intake not oil and heart disease
risk
there are some data showing inverse
relationships between blood levels
of uh fish oil fatty acids and
risk of sudden cardiac death and then
you know you look in 2019 last year
there was a meta-analysis by
hugh and colleagues it's called marine
omega-3 supplementation and
cardiovascular disease
an updated meta-analysis of 13
randomized controlled trials
involving 127 000 participants
i rounded there if you're googling the
title uh so what they found in this
meta-analysis
13 rcts big ones i mean if you got 13
studies and 130
000 people those are big studies
what they found was that marine derived
omega-3 supplementation
was associated with lower risk ratios
of a variety of cardiovascular outcomes
so they looked at
risk of myocardial infarction
death from coronary heart disease they
looked at
the the occurrence of coronary heart
disease they looked at cardiovascular
death
and total cardiovascular disease and so
for these different outcomes
they did find statistically significant
uh reductions in risk
however it didn't have a risk reduction
for stroke
and if you look at these risk ratios
they're not that impressive it's you
know risk ratios of
0.2 0.95 0.97
and so like that's a thing that is lower
than one
and the confidence intervals do not
cross one
so they are statistically significant
but these are
just to be like explicit for listeners
that means that they're finding that
for all of these various outcomes the
the fish oil
reduces risk by between three and eight
percent
right yeah so so it's a modest effect
but it's not like hey
just take this fish oil do all the
unhealthy activities you wish
you're covered like you got this uh but
you know
with all things being considered equal
maybe there is a slight reduction of
risk for these outcomes now
those results are when they removed one
of the trials so that they excluded the
reduce
it trial that's a big acronym because
the reduce it trial
introduced a lot of heterogeneity
because the results were very very very
positive um so so this is kind of the
like let's throw out the really positive
study and see the rest of
the results and those are the numbers i
just gave you and then when they did
include the reduce-it trial
they even found a significant
dose-response relationship um
but there uh and there was not
significant heterogeneity in that dose
response analysis so the idea was
uh you know the higher the dose of the
marine omega-3 supplementation the fish
oil supplementation
uh you know the more impressive the risk
reduction but
this this body of research you know i'm
not saying that i'm 100
confident that fish oil has a notable
protective effect
uh there are other meta-analyses out
there
showing null findings and really what it
comes down to is
which populations do you wish to include
in the analysis you know which study
characteristics do you deem
adequate to include in your meta so
there are meta-analyses that find null
results
where there's no significant benefit and
there are meta-analyses like these where
they find
benefits that are statistically
significant but
very very modest you know three percent
five percent eight percent risk
reduction
uh so this is a nuanced question people
who
literally only study fish oil and its
effects on cardiovascular health
are currently arguing about this stuff
like crazy
so if you think i have a nuanced answer
that is
more impressive than what all the
experts in this field have
you're going to be sorely disappointed
because i don't but the fact that
the idea the contention that there is no
evidence whatsoever
related to this relationship that's it's
simply hyperbolic
so i think we're going to learn more
about it uh in the future
because these trials keep going i think
what if we find an effect
it's going to be modest it's not going
to be a pronounced reduction of
cardiovascular events
it's going to be you know a small
reduction that may or may not be
statistically significant you still are
going to have to
keep an eye on the other more impactful
aspects of cardiovascular health
exercise maintain a healthy body weight
don't smoke things like that
but there could be an independent effect
there if there is
some of the newer trials coming out are
suggesting that
epa alone seems to be more beneficial
than dha or even a combination
of epa and dha and beyond that it looks
like even the specific type of epa
might matter there's different
formulations of epa that have been used
it looks like like some might be more
effective than others
so i'm not sure i buy that fair enough
my libertarian friends have been telling
me that the epa is very ineffective
is that are you being serious god
damn trex you're you're oh god dude i'm
i'm trying to do science here i'm not
trying to make
uh acronym jokes about government
organizations
and most of our audience not most a
large portion's international they don't
know what epa is dude we're like
we're like 45 minutes into this podcast
and it's been like
exclusively about metas and like details
of statistical modeling
i'm trying to just pick my spots and pop
in with with a very stupid joke from
time to time just to keep people engaged
about the environmental protection
agency yes
who libertarians would want to probably
defund
that's the ones i talked to yeah okay
well there you go
all right it's it's comedy it's
statistics dude you know how it goes
when you're like
really really getting into the details
my br my brain is not in a place to be
re receiving jokes no i i understand
and i'll admit it it wasn't a good joke
uh
like i'm i'm just trying to just keep
things light and fun
dude what what could be lighter or more
fun than metal regression
just keep going okay it's fine okay um
now here's where it gets
my main point so i made this post about
fish oil
i think most of the people commenting
didn't listen to the whole thing
because i like didn't re i don't recall
talking about cardiovascular disease
like
at all i might have mentioned it a
little but i don't recall
for sure but i mean when i when i look
at fish oil like
we're in the feel good perform well
business here at stronger by science
like
we're we haven't gone full-blown
longevity mode yet
like we don't do a lot of how to live
forever content
so like i was kind of just talking about
the other stuff so there have been a
couple reviews in the past year
that have looked at potential benefits
of fish oil
for lifters and athletes and you know we
know that epa and dha
you know which are the primary omega-3
fatty acids and fish oil
they're influential components in in
cell membranes when we look at a variety
of cell types you know looking at blood
cells immune cells cardiac tissue
skeletal muscle eye tissue brain cells
other tissues of the nervous system i
mean epa and dha
are certainly important and you know
studies looking at
adjusting epa and dha intake via
supplementation
generally generally report either
neutral or modestly positive effects on
things like muscle recovery cognition
nitric oxide metabolism mental health
inflammation immune function muscle
protein balance
neuromuscular function i mean the list
goes on and on and it's it's findings
that again are
neutral to modestly positive and when
you look at the major concerns that
people have related to
omega or omega-3 and fish oil
supplementation
the issues people talk a lot about
potential bleeding problems
because fish oil supplementation
theoretically could increase bleeding
time by reducing
the speed at which clotting occurs in
the blood
and uh there's also issues or concerns
about
rampant lipid peroxidation that these
fatty acids can be easily oxidized
and that they're going to be negative
outcomes related to that
looking at the actual literature related
to those bleeding concerns
it looks like up to about five-ish grams
per day of fish oil
uh doesn't seem to be a particularly
notable increase in adverse events
related to bleeding um and i don't
recommend even going up to that five
gram per day
intake anyway and as long as you've got
a high quality product with
an antioxidant included a lot of
products put vitamin e
into the blend itself then you're you're
probably not
worrying too much about that lipid
peroxidation issue it seems to be pretty
well taken care of
and so like the whole point of my post
was like i usually take a gram or two
a day of combined epa and dha because
when i look at it i don't see much to
lose there i see some potential for
modest benefit in a variety of different
domains
and i don't see any really notable
adverse events that seem to be
common when you're talking about doses
within that range
and so the way i look at it is like on a
given day i'm going to eat
70 80 grams of fat is it
that bad if like two to four grams of
that comes from fish oil
i i see some potential for upside and i
really don't see
a lot of downside now if you're not
convinced by the data
um i can't fault you for that like it
like i said it's neutral to modestly
positive so if you look at that same
literature and say
uh it's a little bit too mixed for me
and the benefits don't seem pronounced
enough
uh they don't seem large enough in
magnitude dude i'm
i'm fine with that like i i can get on
board with that but for me
the pretty simple cost-benefit analysis
would indicate might be something to be
had here seems like it's probably not a
terrible idea and
i never eat fish so a couple caps a day
and i'm good to go
makes sense to me you don't have any
strong opinions about fish oil
i really don't any additional quips you
want to throw in there
i like salmon it's nice it is nice
um all right so you also have uh
something for this segment i believe
yeah yeah i do so uh last podcast
episode
we discussed a recent study by carvalho
and colleagues about whether preceding
a hypertrophy block with a strength
phase
improved strength and hypertrophy
outcomes
um and i i would say it's uh
it's pretty fair to say that i i was
fairly critical of the study
um indeed to be clear i was never
implying that uh the data themselves
were illegitimate
just that there were some some things
about the statistical reporting that
were kind of weird
uh and the the results seemed to
conflict with
some of the evidence we had up to this
point
but one thing that i did say i recently
found out
was not a uh
appropriate criticism of the study so
one of the things i pointed out was that
based on what is reported in the text
and the tables of the study
um some of the
some of the changes seemed to be
remarkably homogeneous
so one of the ones that i focused on was
within the group that did the
strength phase followed by the
hypertrophy phase during the strength
phase during the first three weeks of
the program
uh vastus lateralis thickness increased
from 22.6 to 22.8 millimeters
that is an increase of one-fifth of one
millimeter
uh and in the table there was a little
asterisk
next to the 22.8 denoting that that was
a statistically significant increase
from baseline
uh and so i said you know look uh
that is a one-fifth of a millimeter
increase that is statistically
significant
that implies absolutely remarkable
homogeneity
way more than we tend to see in the
literature uh
so i said that and if that was correct
i would very much stand by that that uh
commentary
uh but the senior author of the paper uh
barroso
he reached out to me on twitter and let
me know
basically that that was an error in the
paper
so there was a main effect for time
and that's what they were trying to
imply with their asterisks
so the the literal interpretation of the
caption of that figure was incorrect
uh but the the actual like just
you know time zero to time one increase
uh
the the one-fifth of a millimeter
increase that wasn't actually
a statistically significant change um
so my interpretation of the figure
was right like just based on what was
actually presented in the figure
but there was an error in the figure so
um
another thing worth noting is one of the
things i pointed out is there was an
issue
of p-values and confidence intervals not
matching up
he said that that was just a simple
error and they're going to get that
corrected
before the paper goes to final
publication
it's currently pre-pubbed ahead of print
and i gotta say
um again so uh
some people seem to have come away with
the idea that i was
implying that the data lacked integrity
i wasn't trying to make that implication
just that some things about them just
seemed weird
and i gotta say i do feel better about
the study overall
now that bro that uh barroso uh reached
out to me about it
um you know a simple mislabeling
of a table gives me much less pause
than the implication of
absolutely extreme homogeneity uh so
anyway that
is information i acquired after the last
episode went out
that i wanted to share with you guys and
uh
so yeah all right that's good stuff
all right moving on uh we've got uh
we're lumping the selling out segment
into
the research review segment and i'm
gonna do a very brief
a very brief highlight of a study here
because i've been talking for a long
time
and i know you've got a couple studies
that you want to review
so anyway as everyone knows if you're a
listener of the show
if you got supplement needs you go down
to bulk supplements.com
you use the checkout code sbs pod in all
caps
you save incredible amounts of money
five percent off your order i believe
um now another sponsor that we picked up
we've been in some pretty tense
discussions with the suits
over at mass which is a multinational
conglomerate that publishes a research
review every month
and the stipulations of that sponsorship
are pretty
uh extreme you know there's a lot of
requirements so
i have to in order to maintain that
relationship give a
little blurb about a recent article i
did
on glycogen that was published in i
guess that was the december 1st
issue of mass right yeah so
this is something the reason i want to
talk about it on the show uh of course
is to
appease the higher-ups at mass but also
to uh
to kind of come back to a topic we've
talked about previously
on the show so we have talked about
the fact that glycogen is not just
a single thing that is stored uniformly
in muscle there are localized glycogen
compartments that are stored in distinct
areas
within the muscle so we've got
intramyofibrillar
glycogen which is located within the
myofibrils
we've got inter myofibrillar glycogen
which is located between
the myofibrils and we've also got sub
sarcolemma glycogen which is located
just beneath
the sarcolemma and the reason this is
important is because there have been
some studies
largely mechanistic in nature indicating
that the depletion of those different
sub compartments
is not uniform it doesn't always happen
at the same time
and so certain compartments might
deplete more quickly than
others and probably more relevant to
listeners is that
not all of those compartments have the
same physiological
effects when it comes to sustaining
muscle force so
the intra myofibrillar glycogen seems to
be particularly important when it comes
to
sustaining muscle force because those
are very closely
located directly near the sarcoplasmic
reticula
and they facilitate the process of
releasing calcium and then
re-sequestering calcium so that it can
then be
released again and kind of perpetuating
that cycle
that cycle requires atp and the
intramyofibular glycogen
supports that cycle and that cycle that
you know consistent release and
re-sequestering of calcium
is absolutely critical for creating and
sustaining
muscle force now enter
a new study the article i wrote in mass
is called
modest glycogen depletion may impact
lifting performance
more than you think and the study that i
reviewed
is called subcellular localization and
fiber type dependent utilization
of muscle glycogen during heavy
resistance exercise
in elite power and olympic weight
lifters
and that was by hawking and colleagues
in the year 2020
now the reason i wanted to review this
article is because i think it's
very cool and very awesome and it's
extremely relevant to
me and the people i coach and i would
assume most of the people listening to
this podcast
now in the past the role of carbohydrate
for lifters has been debated but the
debate has been pretty short
so it's very common to see notable
figures in the evidence-based fitness
community and in the sports nutrition
world people that do sport nutrition
research
for a living it's very common to see
these people kind of
undermine the importance of dietary
carbohydrate for lifters
and it's largely based on the fact that
prior studies have shown that a single
bout of resistance exercise
might only deplete muscle glycogen
levels by 24
to 40 percent and that's looking at
whole muscle glycogen so the way that's
determined is
you put people through a workout let's
say they're doing a leg workout
then you take a little chunk of their
vastus lateralis you put it in the
blender
grind it all up you get this kind of
homogenized
clump of tissue you look at how much
glycogen is in it
so all those different compartments are
all kind of blended together and you
can't really discriminate
which types of uh compartments have been
depleted it's just
total muscle glycogen um now the the
implication here or the implied
justification
is that you know these exercise bouts
are only depleting whole muscle glycogen
by 24 to 40 percent
and we're gonna kind of pretend or
assume that glycogen works like a gas
tank
and that you're tot like when when
you're driving your car and you've got a
quarter tank of gas or three quarter
tanks
or three quarters of a tank of gas cars
still going it's functioning just fine
it's not until you start really running
out that you're in trouble
and people have been viewing glycogen
the same way if you've only depleted it
24 to 40 percent
you could probably go in do round two
maybe you could get through round three
before you have to worry about getting
down to
ten percent five percent zero percent
glycogen left
now as you could probably assume from
the title of my article that's
really not how glycogen works but this
new study
what they wanted to do was evaluate
glycogen depletion
looking at those distinct compartments
of glycogen
in type 1 fibers and in type 2 muscle
fibers
can i jump in for one second sure so if
you're
if you're someone who likes reasoning by
analogy
which i i think that describes a lot of
people um
so if you're like okay you know maybe
the the gas tank analogy doesn't work
but like what's another way that i could
potentially think of this
um someone brought this up i think on
facebook i believe uh maybe in the mass
group if memory serves
um but another way you could look at
this like
as an analogy uh is like an air tank
so if you're dealing with with some form
of compressed air
uh the the pounds per square inch within
the
container where the air is stored uh
decreases
as air is depleted so you know if you're
dealing with a compressed air canister
at 20 capacity it is not putting out air
at the same force as it did when it was
at 100 capacity um so
that's again not like a perfect analogy
because
you know there's not like intra air in a
compressed air canister
but that that might be a way to think
about
the effects of glycogen on exercise
performance conceptually
that might fit with how it actually
works
a little bit closer than the gas tank
analogy yeah well and the reason i
present the gas tank is to
describe how most people are erroneously
conceptualizing no i i agree
i'm just saying like some a lot of
people do like
analogical conceptions okay and i'm just
saying like a compressed air canister
may be a somewhat closer analogy
yes yeah okay i see what you're saying
yeah yeah yeah so um
this study they were looking at you know
this more kind of localized
view of glycogen depletion and
what they wanted to do was use a pretty
ecologically valid resistance training
exercise so what they had was
you know they had a little warm up they
did four sets of five on the back squat
four sets of five on the deficit
deadlift
and then they did some rearfoot elevated
split squats for four sets of twelve
so a pretty solid workout i think
pretty similar to what a lot of people
do in their training
and again they did use some well-trained
lifters
for this study and the design was
straightforward
come into the lab do the workout we're
going to see how glycogen
was impacted from before the workout to
after the workout
now when you look at total muscle
glycogen it only decreased by about 38
percent and that's actually quite in
line with previous studies like i said
usually 24 to
40 percent of whole muscle glycogen
depletion
however here's where it gets interesting
when they looked at type 2 fibers
the depletion was a little bit more
extensive than it was in type 1 fibers
and then when they looked even closer
within type 2 fibers
the intramyofibrillar stores dropped by
about 54
and all almost half of those fibers
had very substantial depletion of the
intramyofibrillar
glycogen so what they were finding is it
wasn't that
all sub compartments of all fibers were
depleting at the same rate
they found that specifically the
intramyofibrillar glycogen
in many of those type 2 fibers was
disproportionately kind of
running out before other localized areas
of glycogen
and that's pretty important you know it
shows that glycogen depletion
with you know standard resistance
training in people who lift
that glycogen depletion is occurring in
a localized and non-uniform
manner and the particularly notable
depletion that's observed
is occurring in the intra-mylar
intramyofibular area of the type two
fibers
and that is a little bit concerning for
performance because
once those type 2 fibers are
unable to sufficiently fuel
the the process of releasing calcium and
re-sequestering it cyclically
in the sarcoplasmic reticulum that is
highly likely
to tie into fatigue in those fibers and
we might see that
performance starts to deteriorate
and i it's important to point out that
in this study they did not have a
performance test at the end
like they couldn't say oh and this
depletion resulted in a performance
decrement of
x percent but i think you could make a
strong case that when we look at the
other literature in this area
we we can have a pretty decent amount of
faith
that when we carry this forward if we
were to continue doing resistance
training and
and see how this impacts the ability to
generate muscle force
i think you could very closely tie these
observed effects with glycogen
to muscular fatigue over a series of
studies in the last 10 or 15 years this
research group
has demonstrated in a variety of
different research models that
reduced intramyofibular glycogen levels
are associated with impaired calcium
released from the sarcoplasmic reticulum
and that is uh you know when we see that
that starts to get impaired
that calcium release it does appear to
increase muscle fatigue and alter muscle
contractility so
this lab group has done the work to
really put that case together
of course it's always cleaner if you
show it all in one study with
well-trained
lifters but i think what's really
important about this study is
we've had these isolated findings and
some of it is in
toads and some of it is in rodents and
some of it is in endurance athletes
wait it was in toads yeah what do you
think it was in i thought it was in
frogs
i think it was toads i mean it doesn't
matter but
for whatever reason toads are just
funnier to me
[Music]
we'll have to look it up i thought it
was toads it could be frogs
i'll admit i'm a dumbass i don't really
know the difference between toads and
frogs
i one of them lives in drier conditions
right uh
yeah frogs by and large spend
all or most of their time enter around
water and toads mostly live
out out of the water okay all right but
yeah so
the research was kind of scattered among
these different uh models
and one of the big questions was well
does this relate to resistance training
and i think this study is an important
next step in showing
yeah if you do a if you're a trained
lifter and you do a standard resistance
training workout
you do preferentially deplete uh those
localized glycogen stores that we
care the most about and even if you're
only hitting
30 40 total muscle uh
glycogen depletion you might be really
stressing
your glycogen supply uh in the most
critical areas of your type 2 muscle
fibers
and once those are no longer able to
really fully contribute to the force
production process
you're likely to see fatigue occur and
you're likely to see your muscle
contractile property start to
deteriorate
so that's a big deal uh in my opinion i
think it
it necessarily requires that we have a
more nuanced discussion
about carbohydrate for lifting because
for the longest time people just said
screw it
you got 60 left who cares don't worry
about it
now it does not mean that all lifters
need to
inherently adopt a super high carb diet
that would be an inappropriate
extrapolation of these findings
but what it means is we have to at least
when we're trying to figure out our
carbohydrate needs as a lifter
we have to at least consider some key
aspects of you know
how much glycogen are we using and is it
likely that we are replenishing that
between
sessions so if you're eating at
maintenance calories or above and you've
got a moderate carb diet at least so
let's say you've got at least 40 percent
of your calories coming from carbs
and if you're resting at least 24 hours
between
high intensity bouts with the same
muscle group you probably still don't
have to worry too much
about your glycogen levels you're
probably going to be able to
sufficiently replenish between bouts
now if you are in a big energy deficit
or you're on a really low carb diet or
you perform multiple exercise bouts
for the same muscle group with really
glycogen dependent uh
intensities and those multiple bouts are
occurring within a 24-hour period
then muscle glycogen replenishment could
probably be an influential factor that
you should be considering
when it comes to your carbohydrate
strategy so um
again i don't think the study
necessarily means everyone has to go on
a high carb diet i think there are still
ways that you can make low carb diets
work
very effectively for lifters but you
have to very carefully consider
you know what is your energy balance are
you in a deficit or a surplus what's
your carb intake
how glycolytic is the activity that
you're doing
what's your training volume and training
frequency you get you got to at least be
mindful of making sure that
if you are going to deplete muscle
glycogen even if it's only going to be
30 or 40 percent total muscle glycogen
depletion
you got to get that replenished before
you're going to go do a glycolytic bout
with that same muscle group
and if you're in a caloric deficit it is
harder one of the things that a lot of
people overlook is
if you're in a caloric deficit and you
think oh but i had you know
150 grams of carbs yesterday how much
could i really need well
if you're in a deficit a lot of those
carbs are going to get used for
energy needs you know they're not going
to make it to
the muscle to be scored to be stored as
glycogen you're going to burn through
them
to meet your exercise energy needs and
your resting energy needs
so you have to get in a deficit a little
bit more creative about how you're going
to effectively
replenish that glycogen so the exciting
thing is then going to be what do we do
from here a lot of good conversations
about
if you are in a deficit and you do have
a high training frequency
and your repetition and intensity ranges
are pretty glycolytic
what do you do is it intro workout carb
supplementation is it post workout
supplementation is it
higher priority on the pre-workout meal
you could have some good arguments about
that and
this line of research stops short of the
practical application we don't know
exactly
when it comes to those specific
scenarios we really have to put our
put a lot of thought into it and figure
out what's the best way to do it you can
have some good arguments but at the very
least
there are arguments worth having it is a
dietary factor
that deserves a lot more consideration
than it's been given
makes sense to me all right so greg what
are you talking about here with your
research review uh yes i'm gonna be
talking about
myonuclei a little bit uh talk about
some
rodent research uh ooh eric
i learned a fun fact what's that do you
know where
the name for muscle comes from
hmm i assume it's
carn something but where would that come
from
no like the actual word muscle oh in
english
yeah uh no i was i was thinking like
let's get back to latin
no where does it come from so it does
come from latin okay uh
it comes from it's derived from the
latin
term for little mouse huh
uh and i i don't think um
like linguistic anthropologists are
positive
how that came from but the the current
leading hypothesis is that like
apparently when you flex your bicep
it looks enough like a mouse moving
under the skin with like the tendon
as the little tail coming off of it that
they're just like oh yeah little mouse
well that's like uh what's the what's
the origin again for
is it hippopotamus uh
isn't that water horse i forget hip yeah
yeah cause it because hippo
is i believe that's like greek for horse
uh yeah it's
it's uh the most obvious i think in
german
uh it's knope faired which just means
nile horse
yeah so like yeah you look at a bicep
and you think that's a mouse
yeah pretty much you look at a
hippopotamus and you're like dude that
as far as i can tell that's just a horse
and water oh do you know what the
the leading hypothesis for where um
myths of uh cyclopses came from
is no elephants
so if you look at an elephant skull um
just like the entire front of the skull
just isn't there
like it it looks like it looks like
there's a single eye hole so like if you
look
at a human skull there's like two eye
holes uh
and like in elephant skull there's just
like one one big hole in the middle of
the skull
and it looks like uh it looks like there
would just be one eye hole there and
apparently like
uh during homer's time they came across
uh elephant skulls they're like oh yeah
this is probably just some big scary
thing with one eye
cyclops dude that would have been
terrifying to like if you didn't know
what an
elephant looked like and you found that
skull oh yeah
that would have been look at this thing
oh wow
that is i assume that has something it's
the trunk right
the the trunks doing well no the truck
would be lower that's the eyes
like they're uh well it's partially due
to the trunk i think i think the uh
the nasal passages and like the eyes are
kind of like all close enough that they
just have one opening there and then
they're in the middle of the skull that
i like elephants but that's a strange
system
yeah i would have done it a little bit
differently it's pretty spooky man
i don't want a big hole a big soft hole
in the center of my face
i mean you know one thing to consider is
like they're tall enough that nothing is
gonna
really get up there and threaten that
unless like there was a particularly
angry giraffe
that's true so i mean like so you just
have to be nice to the giraffes and
you're
you're good i guess so yeah um
anyway yeah let's uh let's talk about
myonuclei
so uh shout out to friend of the pod
actual friend of the pod not fake friend
eric helms
a friend of the pod alex coliari turner
um
he sent some more cool
my nuclei research my way um
this shit's really dense uh most of the
time when i talk about a study on the
podcast
i am like 95
plus confident that i'm understanding
everything
going on uh i'm still above 50
confidence here but now it's closer to
like 80 90
uh this is somewhere this is somewhat
outside my wheelhouse and it's very
technical stuff
um but it's cool enough that i figure
it's at least worth taking a swipe at it
uh
and if i [ __ ] it up bad enough we can
just get alex back on and he can set us
straight
good stuff so with that massive caveat
out of the way
uh let's get into it so one of the
papers he sent me
was titled my nuclear content regulates
cell size
with similar scaling properties in mice
and humans
by hanson and colleagues and so
one of the reasons i wanted to talk
about this is in a recent episode
we discussed myonuclei a bit uh in
in particular how they may or may not
relate
to muscle memory so um
for a bit there uh it was thought that
myonuclei
may be the driver of the muscle memory
phenomenon
um and basically more research is
suggesting like yeah maybe they play a
role to some degree but probably aren't
like
the singular driver and may not even
play the dominant role
um but i don't want to make it sound
like
myonuclei are either unimportant or not
super super interesting because i think
they are still super super interesting
and so a recent study suggests that you
know maybe they aren't the driver of
muscle memory but they might be
the driver or at least like one of the
major things
uh placing constraints on hypertrophy
of muscle fiber size and so that's why i
wanted to talk about this like i've
mentioned this on the podcast before
one of the questions that fascinates me
is like
why why the [ __ ] do we stop growing
because if you think about if you think
about muscle growth just in terms of
like muscle protein synthesis
um i don't think we've i don't think
we've really come across a population
yet where
you can't put them through some
resistance training and give them some
protein
and notice uh in elevation and muscle
protein synthesis
and in trained lifters you don't see
like any enormous increase in muscle
protein breakdown either so like
on the surface you just look at protein
stuff and you're just like
why why do we plateau like why don't
people just kind of grow indefinitely
um and so like that that's something
that
i think about a lot because like that's
obviously an important question that we
don't
that most research isn't designed to
investigate
uh so when alex sent me the study i was
very very uh interested in it
so um basically what they were doing in
this study is they were looking at the
relationships
between myonuclear number per fiber
fiber volume and fiber surface area
both in mice and humans and what and
basically they wanted to see like
what what do my nuclei scale with
like are they do they scale linearly
with fiber volume do they scale linearly
with surface area
and what they found is that uh
myonuclear content
scales linearly with a muscle fiber
surface area
uh and just just based on how
volume equations work uh
when surface area increases volume
increases faster
so you can you can see this uh
um like pretty easily if you talk about
like the
surface area of like a cube
or something like if you double the the
sides
of a cube um the surface area will
the the volume will increase at a cubic
rate
and the surface area will increase at a
square rate um so
so volume increases faster than surface
area does
and so essentially what you see is that
in larger fibers
the relationship between surface area
and myonuclear number
is the same as smaller fibers but larger
fibers have
fewer myonucleic per unit of fiber
volume
than smaller fibers do
and the basic idea posited by the
researchers here
is that that might place a constraint
on how large a muscle fiber could then
become
stated conversely we we've talked about
before the idea of a myonuclear domain
limit
basically there is a maximum volume
of cytoplasm that each myonucleus can
like quote unquote oversee
and so if the amount of volume per
myonuclei inherently increases as fibers
get larger
because the myonuclei are scaling with
surface area
uh just just by virtue of that
relationship
existing and hypertrophy occurring as
fibers get larger
you will run into your myonuclear domain
limit
and then in order to keep growing you
would basically have to break the
relationship
between myonuclear number uh and
fiber surface area like you you would
need to have more myonuclei per unit of
surface area
for volume to continue increasing and
since
this seems to be a fairly fixed
relationship
in at least two different species across
a pretty wide array of fiber sizes
um who knows maybe that isn't possible
and maybe this is
something that that does place that
upward constraint
on how large fibers can be and therefore
the limits of
hypertrophy um
so uh in previous discussions of
uh myonuclear domain limit the focus was
more
on like quote unquote normal hypertrophy
so
like could fibers uh or like
how fibers grow um
and like whether or not people needed to
accrue more myonuclei
in in order for fibers to keep growing
basically this takes things a step
further and posits that myonuclear
domains
inherently grow as fibers grow and that
fibers might reach a point where they
simply can't grow
without exceeding the myonuclear domain
limit because myonuclear content is
constrained by
surface area um it's worth noting
that myonuclear domain limits have been
exceeded in the past in some
experimental models so
a common example people might bring up
is
myostatin mutants so like mice that are
genetically engineered
to not produce myostatin they get super
super big
and they have larger myonuclear domains
so like fiber volume increases
disproportionate
to um to my nuclear number um
but another thing we see in those mice
is that they
their muscles tend to be somewhat
dysfunctional so they're less
strong per unit of size than
mice who aren't myostatin knockout mice
so like you know maybe we can exceed
so-called myonuclear domain limits but
there might be some functional
limitations that come
that come along with that and you know
it might only be possible
in like [ __ ] up breeds of mice that
are genetically engineered to have
a specific like myostatin mutation uh
it doesn't just have to be genetic
engineering um
i guess it's worth noting so like some
whippets called bully whippets like a
breed
of dog are also myostatin mutants uh and
belgian blue bulls
uh well just belgian blue cattle are
like have been bred to be
myostatin mutants uh i met some of those
in belgium a couple years ago
yeah how cool was that to see him in
person you know so
it was cool on a couple levels one
they were very chill uh like i saw them
uh uh thomas the guy that we were
traveling belgium with
uh i was like thomas are those belgian
blues and he was like
oh yeah like that is the dominant breed
of cattle here like
uh i thought that it was just like kind
of a
thing that was maybe like kind of a
novelty but i think that's like the
the majority of belgian beef production
which surprised me um and actually
they're a very good animal for that
because
uh one their meat is very lean so they
have less fat on them than other
like cattle breeds because they're
shredded they're not just big yeah
they're [ __ ] shredded
yeah they're yeah they're huge and
shredded yeah and their their feed
efficiency is pretty high
uh because they're myostatin mutants
like for every
unit of feed you feed them they put on a
pretty
large proportion of muscle in response
to that
uh so anyway like it makes sense but
like it just kind of surprised me i
thought that they
they were just kind of a novelty animal
um
so anyway i was like oh [ __ ] stop the
car i want to i want to go say hey to
the cows
uh and they just like came up to the
fence they were super gentle like
they let me pet them i fed them some
grass um
and they were like they are so freaky
in person yeah they're so jacked
and also so gentle um but the other
thing that surprised me is like i had
only seen pictures of them on the
internet
and like i saw how muscular they were
and in my head
i was mapping that onto like an angus
steer
because like there were cattle farms
where i grew up and i'm used to seeing
angus cattle because like that's what's
raised for beef in the u.s for the most
part
yeah um and like angus cattle are
[ __ ] huge
they're enormous like their stature yeah
yeah like they're
they're tall and they're they're super
wide yeah uh but like very tall
just massive creatures uh and i just
assumed that belgian blues would be like
the skeletons would be comparable to
angus cattle
they were actually like kind of small um
like
they were short they were very stocky
very muscular
um but i was like kind of surprised at
how little they are
and i think that's just because american
cattle are so big
yeah but anyway that was a very cool
experience uh anyway
myonuclear mutant or myostatin mutants
have
some weird stuff with with myonuclei
that probably
doesn't apply to creatures that don't
have myostatin deficiencies
but speaking of other genetically
engineered critters there was another
study that alex sent me
by kramer and colleagues titled nuclear
numbers in
syncital muscle fibers promote size but
limit the development of larger
myonuclear domains
and so essentially what they did in this
study is they
genetically engineered some mice to
mess with a protein that affects
myonuclear fusion so
basically like when satellite cells
differentiated they would have a harder
time
fusing to the uh to the muscle fibers to
limit myonuclear number in these mutant
mice
and they basically wanted to see what
effect that would have
so to quote from the abstract i think
this lays it out pretty well
here we directly explore the assumed
causal relationship
between multinucleation and
establishment of normal size through
titration of myonuclear numbers
during mouse neonatal development three
independent mouse models where
myonuclear numbers were reduced by 75 55
or
25 percent led to the discovery that
myonuclei possess a reserve capacity to
support
larger functional cytoplasmic volumes in
developing myofibers
surprisingly the results revealed an
inverse relationship between
nuclei numbers and reserve capacity we
propose that as myonuclear numbers
increase the range of
transcriptional return on a per nuclear
basis
and myofibers diminishes which accounts
for both the absolute
reliance developing myofibers have on
nuclear accrual to establish size
and the limits of adaptability in adult
skeletal muscle so
basically um they found that fibers
with the reduced myonuclear content were
smaller
than fibers that were where my nuclei
could fuse normally
but they found that the fibers with
fewer myonuclei could support
larger myonuclear domains so you know
if there was a 55 reduction
in um in my nuclei that wouldn't lead to
a 55
reduction in fiber size it might only be
like a 20
reduction or something like that uh but
conversely as fibers got larger the
ability of each fiber
to support larger myonuclear domains
decreased
so basically there seems to be an
inverse relationship between
fiber size and the myonuclear domains
that can be supported
like per nucleus and so like this raises
a question of like
why is that the first thing that came to
mind for me is it might just be a
diffusion problem
so essentially if you have a a muscle
fiber that is smaller in cross-sectional
area
um like the the myonuclei
are largely located near the surface of
the muscle fiber and so if you have
a muscle fiber of smaller
cross-sectional area or
like smaller diameter the middle of that
muscle fiber is closer to each
myonucleus like there's just a shorter
diffusion distance
and like stuff in cells still has to
move um
like that's something that i think
people don't think about just like the
kinetics of
all of those molecules and so like you
know if you're a nucleus and you want to
signal and say like hey make some more
myosin
uh you're gonna you're gonna get red and
you're gonna
send some messenger rna out to a
ribosome um
and it's gonna produce that myosin and
it's gonna link up with
like other contractile proteins and like
you know
that's a whole thing um but like the
mrna has to diffuse through the cell
to a ribosome and then like the protein
has to
go to where it needs to be for like the
structural function
uh within the cell and so like one of
the things that came to mind is just
like
as volumes of fibers get larger
uh the distance from like a myonucleus
to the furthest point that it might be
like quote unquote overseeing
just naturally gets larger um so that
that might be
some sort of constraint there we see a
similar thing with oxygen
actually um so one of the reasons that
it is inefficient for endurance athletes
to be too muscular
is if their muscle fibers get larger the
diffusion distance for oxygen increases
and so like
their fibers just function a bit less
efficiently for oxidative metabolism
so like a kind of you know maybe a
similar thing is going on with myonuclei
um the authors posit that
uh nuclear density may basically
regulate itself
so maybe the nuclei's themselves are
communicating in some way
uh we don't understand um to basically
say like hey this is my turf
here on the surface of the fiber you
can't get too close to me
um so something like that could be going
on or it could be that the nuclei
themselves um or it could be that
basically
um myonuclear domain size is regulated
by transcription factors so basically
there might be
a finite amount of transcription factors
in the cell
uh and if nuclei got and as nuclei get
closer and closer
the transcriptional capacity per nucleus
decreases because there there is like a
finite amount of
transcription factors that the nuclei
are like kind of competing for
i guess um so basically like greater
nuclear density on the surface of the
fiber would lower the transcriptional
capacity per nucleus
um but regardless this dovetails pretty
well with the other study
um further suggesting that myonuclei
could limit fiber size um so
basically you know if both
the both the myonuclear number scaling
with the surface area of the fiber
that's going to
make fibers eventually hit their
myonuclear domain limit
because the volume is increasing
disproportionately to surface area
and furthermore as the density of these
myonuclei
increases the transcriptional capacity
per nuclei
decreases um so basically like you could
ask yourself like well okay like maybe
we could find a way to exceed the
myonuclear domain limit but
this is essentially implying that the
myonuclear domain limit itself
inherently gets smaller and smaller as
myonuclear density gets higher and
higher
um so that that just further reinforces
that this mechanism
could be what is constraining fiber size
and therefore hypertrophy
um one just like kind of interesting
thing i noted
is cross-sectionally within like a
population of muscle fibers
contractile force also scales with uh
fiber diameter which which would scale
with uh
with surface area rather than
fiber cross-sectional area ergo
contractile force scales linearly with
myonuclear content
not fiber cross-sectional area
and like i don't know what to do with
that um
that could just be like a weird little
coincidence but
you know it's just a thing i guess for
you to stew on
um and it's a connection that i would
like to see explored
but anyway um this stuff might seem kind
of
arcane but it does lead us to some
interesting questions and or
implications
uh so the first implication is that the
upper limit of hypertrophy may be
constrained
to some degree by the number of muscle
fibers you're born with
so there was a study by mcdougall and
colleagues i believe from 1982
which supports this to some degree so
in that study they they compared um
bodybuilders and powerlifters against
untrained controls and then they had the
untrained controls trained for six
months
and then they compared various things
about the
now six month trained people against the
power lifters and bodybuilders and
basically they found that at
after six months of training the power
lifters and bodybuilders still had way
more muscle
than the previously untrained folks
but their um like their fiber size
was pretty comparable um which
seems to suggest that the bodybuilders
and powerlifters just had way more
muscle fibers
than these folks who just got into
training
which then leads us to kind of a second
question
and that is to what degree is is
hyperplasia
contributing to ongoing muscle growth um
so a general observation i've had is
that
as people train and and seem to approach
their like quote unquote genetic limit
um some people do kind of seem to hit a
hard limit
and some people seem to kind of shift to
a more gradual
phase of growth where like you know over
decades they do
keep gaining muscle but it's just at a
very very gradual
rate um and an idea that's been floating
around in the back of my mind
is like could that be due to different
propensities towards hyperplasia like
you know maybe there's inherent
differences in how well people
hypertrophy and there might be
inherent differences in how efficiently
hyperplasia occurs in humans as well
um it's worth noting i guess we've
talked about hyperplasia on the podcast
before i'm not going to re-litigate that
whole thing
it's controversial whether hyperplasia
occurs in humans at all
i am very strongly on team hyperplasia
mostly because it has been observed in
really
every animal model where we've tried to
observe it
um even using like non-extreme
interventions and so like it would be
kind of surprising if it occurred in
like basically every animal
except for humans uh so i'm i was gonna
say isn't there some interesting stuff
about
dominant versus non-dominant limbs in
humans as well
yeah so um your non-dominant side
tibialis anterior
probably gets more just general work on
a day-to-day basis because that's like
what what your stance leg would be when
you're doing stuff
with your dominant leg um and when
when people so there was a study where
like people died
and they cut out their tibialis
interiors and compared fiber numbers
between the dominant and
and non-dominant side uh and the
non-dominant leg
tibialis anterior had about 11 more
muscle fibers than the dominant side did
and so like that's theorized to be like
just as a result
like hyperplasia resulting from
day-to-day activities
one would assume that if hyperplasia
were to occur
it would probably occur to a greater
degree from resistance training
than just like walking i guess um
so yeah there's some indirect evidence
in humans as well
um so anyway we're we're nowhere close
to knowing the intricacies of
hyperplasia
in human models um but
this this whole line of research just
makes me wonder about it more so if if
myonuclear content and myonuclear domain
limits
are are basically placing a hard cap
on how large each fiber can be
theoretically
one would then assume that like folks
could grow up to that limit and then if
hyperplasia doesn't occur
like growth is done capiche it's over um
so like because people do seem to keep
growing
over time uh a lot of people even though
very gradually
my thinking is that that very gradual
but continued rate of growth um
may be due to hyperplasia more so than
hypertrophy
um but but obviously we would need more
research to tease that out
um a third implication
of this of this line of research is
we could now work out the theoretical
upper limit of muscle fiber
cross-sectional area
um we have the information to do that
now uh
under the assumption that the myonuclear
domain limits are actually hard limits
like basically
you know if we know surface areas
volumes and
myonuclear domain limits you could then
be able to compute
the maximal per fiber cross-sectional
area
i could do that i didn't because i was
outlining this
last night and it is currently christmas
week and i had more important things to
do
but if someone wants to work that out
all of the pieces are in play that
we could now figure that out uh which i
think is pretty cool
and the fourth question
slash kind of implication that this
brings up
just makes me wonder about is like what
the [ __ ] are steroids doing
and uh like exogenous anabolics so
are they um like are they
allowing maybe for larger myonuclear
domains by enhancing
the transcriptional capacity of each
myonucleus that's a possibility
are they maybe allowing for a
disproportionate increase
in myonuclei myonuclei per unit
of fiber surface area that's a
possibility
some research by katy kadi shows that
exogenous testosterone does increase
rates of myonuclear accretion so like
that's a possibility um
do they maybe promote hyperplasia uh
that is another possibility or uh is it
multiple of those options all of the
above who's to say um
but yeah i mean basically if if we now
have a a mathematical relationship
that describes how large fibers
should be able to get uh well i mean i
guess another possibility is like maybe
there is
some sub constraint and most people
never reach that theoretical upper limit
of fiber size
and maybe that's all steroids are doing
like they're they're helping people
reach that theoretical limit um if
uh if someone were to um uh
take the information in these studies
and work out what that theoretical limit
of fiber size is
um let me know so the the largest fibers
i've seen reported in the literature
um in humans are
like god i'm i don't know units i think
it's
it's somewhere in the neighborhood of
like 10 to 12 000
uh square micrometers so you could work
that out
if you know if the number's like 25 000
or something like that it's like oh okay
now i know what steroids are doing
huma humans training drug free just
aren't approaching that theoretical
limit in the first place
uh but anyway i don't know that's just
another thing to ponder and consider but
overall
i think this is a very very interesting
and very cool line of research um
because yeah like up to this point we to
my mind we didn't have
a super clear candidate for
what might be placing upward constraints
on fiber size and hypertrophy
and this seems to be a really really
strong candidate
that i thought was super super cool um
and since
i've recently cast aspersions
on the possibility that that myonuclei
are like
a driver of muscle memory i just wanted
to bring up
another phenomenon that they
could be contributing to because i i do
think myonuclei are
are fascinating uh and that it's still
an area of
of research that's very very much worth
watching
so i remember i believe the year was
2018 and you and i were having a
discussion and you said you know what we
ought to do eric
we ought to write an article about what
ultimately constrains muscle growth
and we didn't
and i was a little nervous that you were
going to say okay
let's go ahead and do it now because up
until about
20 minutes ago i don't know what the
hell we would have written well
so i was thinking we could not like
confidently say this is what it is but
basically throughout like yeah here here
are some possibilities based on
some things that are kicking around um
so i i was previously thinking myonuclei
before i wasn't thinking like
you know this discordance between um
surface areas and volumes i was thinking
more along the lines of like you know
maybe you just reach a point
where you can't fuse more myonuclei you
hit your myonuclear domain limit like
maybe that's what's constraining things
um another thing i had in mind
uh is is uh my buddy frances hallway
his idea of like muscle to bone ratios
potentially constraining things like
we know that there is a pretty fair
amount of crosstalk between
muscle tissue and bone tissue um and
that they
can like mutually regulate the
metabolism
within each other to some degree um and
so he
he basically has a database of athletes
finding that like
among the the most muscular athletes in
his database
there's a there seems to be like a
relatively
hard ish limit on the like
muscle to bone ratios observed in
in the the athletes in a sample
so i thought that might be worth
chatting about and honestly that's
another thing i'd love to see more
research on like crosstalk between
muscle and bone i think is
super important uh bone is an endocrine
organ
uh to a degree that i think a lot of
people don't appreciate and i i think
it's like
super slept on uh for muscle metabolism
um you know i'm not positing that it's
like a panacea
or anything but it's an area where i
would like to see more research like
with a resistance training focus
another thing that i had in mind is like
it might be
related to connective tissue to some
degree so like we we know that
connective tissue
can thicken and get stronger in response
to
loading but like that does basically
like tendons do
seem to be less abs
like less adaptable on a relative basis
than muscle and so like you know
potentially
um you know the the force your muscle
can create uh
reaches like basically the amount of
force that your tendons are comfortable
transmitting
uh and just through protective
mechanisms then like the
the contractile force that your muscles
are producing
kind of like plateaus and like maybe
therefore you can't
then disrupt homeostasis enough to get
a post-exercise hypertrophic signaling
response
um so those were the three three ideas i
had kicking around in my head that
again not claiming to know for sure that
any of those things were the things that
limited hypertrophy but just based on
like indirect [ __ ]
like that those are the types of things
where it might be interesting to
talk about and discuss mechanisms a
little bit and you know
like uh like people in a college dorm
room like instead of talking about like
ah what's the meaning of life man and
like no one knowing the answer it's like
oh
what constrains muscle growth man and
just kind of like throwing some ideas
out there
so that's what i had in mind at the time
but uh
this this is obviously another very
strong candidate that now has
more experimental evidence supporting it
than any of those other three options i
just threw out there
yeah so do you feel like you're closer
to uh
opening up a document and beginning that
that article someday
uh no
good because i don't want to do it uh
yeah i i it seems like the
the myonuclei stuff there are
three or four research groups out there
that are doing a pretty fair amount
of like very very cool [ __ ] in the area
right now
um i don't know man i'm hoping some of
that will pan out
uh to give us some clearer answers yeah
let them figure it out before we uh
start writing about it yeah and i mean
ultimately like that
that basic rundown uh that i just gave
you
that would have been the article but it
would have been like
eight to ten times longer with a lot
more citations yeah um but like those
were the ideas
now the audience knows those ideas yeah
i mean in the time since we had that
discussion we decided to uh
try this whole audio format and that's
made it
a lot easier to get some ideas out there
with without writing
you know thousands upon thousands of
words
so did we did we settle on a topic to
play us out
you know i think i think the best thing
to do
because this is going to be our last
episode of 2020 it is
uh it's just to thank the audience so
um being very transparent
for a moment uh when
everything started kicking off in
february and march
we were we were legitimately
scared about how this year might go uh
with gyms closing uh
would people still be consuming lifting
content uh content about a a hobby that
a lot of them
would be unable to engage in at least
for for a time
um with people getting laid off and like
salaries getting cut back
like we are any of our products you buy
are the definition of like discretionary
spending
so uh you know with that getting
constrained like we were
afraid that the businesses were gonna
really really take a pretty big hit
um and honestly like
this year has gone
i mean obviously not like perfectly uh
but
it's it's gone way better than we could
have
hoped for really um and and we owe that
to you folks listening um
you know we uh i mean
on a very literal basis uh without you
we would not have a business we would
wind up sleeping on the streets
um and uh yeah so we
we really uh appreciate everyone who's
who's listened to the podcast who's uh
you know
used our discount code at bulk
supplements that's that's really kept
the lights on
um and yeah we we uh we love you
and we hope that everyone is having a
great holiday season absolutely we hope
everyone has a great holiday um
i echo everything you just said um
stronger by science community out there
came through in a big way this year
and aside from just keeping the business
viable
and us under roofs um
you know the the uh fireside chat series
you know that one of the reasons that we
wanted to have that was
boy these are some scary uncertain times
and uh
it'd be nice to just kind of hang out
and chat with whoever's out there you
know so
we were hoping that it would be a
helpful thing for everyone listening to
just like
not talk about kovid for 60 to 90
minutes and relax but
honestly i i found it really helpful to
just talk to the world
and just kind of chill and and kind of
create a social thing out of it
so even just that just the audience
being there
and kind of following along with us
throughout the year it's been huge
it's meant a lot to to both of us yeah
and uh
you guys also um raised
a fair a fair bit of money for good
causes this year as well
um so the the two mass sales that we
held this year
um they so a portion
of proceeds went to uh food banks for
the first one
and american it's not american society
for suicide prevention what is it
american foundation yeah um
so between those two i think somewhere
in the neighborhood of about 30 000
bucks
were raised um so you know i mean that's
that's not like on on the scale of like
aid that governments can provide but
like
that's that's a good chunk of change
going towards
um going towards really positive things
uh and you guys were the ones who did
that
absolutely so uh thank you so much for
your continued support
um this is the final episode of the
calendar year 2020 but we're going to be
back
in 2021 better than ever and i promise
we're going to try
even harder thank you for listening to
the stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified
healthcare professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you